Speaker 1: Hey, you have to see this. The Texas
attorney general, Ken Paxton, says he is willing
and able to defend a law that bans gay sex in
private. Now, these are sometimes referred to
as sodomy laws. And obviously, if you are a small
government conservative, the first thing you would
do is start trying to pass laws about what people
can do in the privacy of their own bedroom. No,
that's not at all what you would do. But it is a
tired example of how the values they state are,
not the actual values they espouse when it is
no longer convenient to them. It is absurd and
terrifying that Ken Paxton is saying, Hey, let's
look at ways to roll back LGBT rights. I mean,
the fact that that's happening, even in some
general sense, is horrifying. We maybe naively
hoped in 2015, after the gay marriage decision,
that we were all moving beyond these issues of
trying to limit the rights of LGBT people that
we have seen from the right, we very quickly
realized they're not giving up. They're just going
to shift the battle lines. They shifted from gay
marriage to, for example, religious freedom. To
discriminate against gay people. Bathroom stuff,
trans. You all know the stuff. So now we hear
from Ken Paxton. I have a clip here. He is,
of course, always couching this, as states should
get to decide what types of sex people can have.
In their bedroom. But we're not falling
for it. Take a look at this. Me? Would you,
as attorney general, be comfortable defending a
law that once again outlawed sodomy? The choirboy
Lawrence again, or Griswold or gay marriage?
They came from the state legislature to to put
to the test what Justice Thomas said.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, there's all
kinds of issues here, but certainly the
Supreme Court has stepped in the issues
that I don't think there was any constitutional
provision dealing with. They were legislative
issues. Wow. And this is one of those issues.
Speaker 1: And there may be more. So understand
the gist of what he is saying, because these
guys are pretty damn good at using euphemisms
and talking around issues. What Ken Paxton
fundamentally is saying is that the Supreme Court
has overstepped the same way that they say, well,
the Supreme Court overstepped on gay marriage,
the Supreme Court overstepped on Roe v Wade, which
they've since been able to get Roe rolled back.
And they say states should get to decide
these things. But at the end of the day,
this is very much like those who say
the Civil War was not about slavery,
it was about states rights. Ah, but it
was not about states rights to determine
we're going to use the entire the centimeter.
Right. It was about states rights to determine
they want to continue making it legal to own
people and force them to do work for you as
slaves. And very much the same way. What Ken
Paxton is saying here is I can very much defend
the laws in which Texas might ban gay sex in the
privacy of bedrooms and make it a crime which is
insanely overreaching for government, especially
for people claiming that they are small government
conservatives. He's going to say it that way.
This is it. We believe it can be defended because
the Supreme Court has overreached in certain ways
beyond where we believe it will at a lower level.
It's a very clear indication that Paxton and other
so-called conservatives are not only comfortable
but are actively working and interested in rolling
back LGTB LGBT rights. We said that this would
happen right after the Roe v Wade decision. It
is a disgusting violation of human rights. It's
a step towards more discrimination, towards more
oppression, and it goes against their own stated
principles. And the fact that Paxton is willing
to publicly come out and say discriminatory,
disgusting, oppressive law. Well, we're going
to defend states rights because that's my job
under the Constitution. It shows either or both.
He doesn't actually understand what it means to
have rights or he assumes the people who support
him don't. And that's much the way that Fox News
operates. Like, I don't literally think Fox News
hosts hosts believe a lot of the crap they say,
but they believe their audience will believe
it and they're mostly correct. And that has
been much of Ken Paxton and in general, the
Texas governor and lieutenant governor's M.O.,
which is we will assume our voters don't know the
difference and this stuff will sound pretty damn
good to them. So extraordinarily dangerous.
Whether Paxton is actually going to fight to,
again, ban certain types of sex in people's
private homes between consenting adults,
I don't know. I'm hoping it doesn't actually
get to that point. But he's certainly saying
all the things that make us think that's what's
coming. Make sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show. What a week of programs we have for you.